This month, Congress will decide the fate
of the Export-Import Bank. EXIM is a
federal agency that subsidizes US
exports by extending taxpayer-backed
financing to overseas buyers, including
foreign governments and companies. Ex-Im's
charter expires September 30th, but
Congress has taken up a bill to renew
the agency for ten more years. Without
EXIMs loans and loan guarantees, the
sponsors argue, US exporters would suffer
from a lack of financing. But that's not
what recent history has shown us. In 2015,
conservative opposition caused the
bank's charter to lapse and its board to
lose a quorum, so for nearly four years
EXIM couldn't finance large deals. What
happened to financing for aircraft, which
is EXIM's main line of business? It
blossomed like never before!
You see, Boeing assembled a consortium of
lenders and insurers who found all sorts
of innovative ways to finance planes.
That's not surprising: When government
steps out of the way, the market steps in.
EXIM's clients do like government
financing, but that doesn't mean they
need it. What do you think? Should
Congress reauthorize Export-Import Bank
or kill it? Let us know in our poll. Also,
let us know what other topics you'd like
scholars to cover in 60 seconds, and be
sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI.